I think Superbowl commercial is the most
underpriced ad in the world if you said
you have 25 million dollars to sell
something I would buy Superbowl first
then I would look at Facebook because I
know I have all of America's attention
you're the sport of watching the
commercial is real you're gonna either
watch it on YouTube or you gonna watch
it during the game so right now it's
Facebook video I'm dying to see what
snapchats scaled API product is which is
videos in between stories but how are we
gonna react are we gonna be sad that
there's video Instagram video has gotten
a lot better literally in the last 60
days so I'm starting to get a little bit
more excited about that YouTube's new
pre-roll based on people's search that's
really interesting so it's one thing to
run a video in front of a Sports
highlight it's another thing to run a
video in front of somebody who last week
searched Knicks season tickets like you
have a totally different lead there so
it's a you know whereas I used to make
fun of pre-roll and I even just did
right now I didn't go further down which
is but there's one product Google just
put out that I'm very fascinated by
which is this search thing but keep
going that's it yeah so that's the sin
of you Facebook video is so underpriced
it would make your head spin